to bring you a little bit more on what
happened in Nottingham yesterday we
brought you the news a short while ago
that the third victim has been named as
Ian Coates we can now bring you an image
of Mr Coates he was a school caretaker
he is the man who was apparently dragged
from his van the white van and stabbed
left to die in the street his family say
that he was in his 60s he was 60 years
old
school caretaker from Nottingham who has
been now officially named by the
authorities up there along with the two
youngsters who died Barnaby Weber and
Grace Kumar as well so this is the third
victim of the Nottingham attack has now
been pictured a school caretaker who was
dragged from his van and stabbed